with the three of us in this marriage so
it's a bit crowded the crown has brought
us season after season of compelling
drama and as the characters change over
the course of their lives so too do the
actors playing them with so many actors
covering a set number of characters
comes many stories about making it all
happen what do actors from all seasons
of the crown have to say about making
the show stick around to find out number
one all hail the queen in the latest
season of the crown the Monarch herself
is played by actor Imelda Stanton we
wonder if perhaps Imelda had one of the
most daunting tasks in the role as she
was playing the Elizabeth that we
perhaps know best here's what she had to
say about playing the role I think the
challenge that I felt for myself the
extra challenge if there wasn't enough
on my plate was to be the queen that
people recognized much more now the
older Queen Claire foy's version was
almost a costume drama because it seemed
so long ago and then Olivia Coleman's
was again like a period piece this
season just feels so much more present I
thought I can't fool anyone now
number two Manville for Margaret the
crown actor Leslie Manville gives us two
seasons in the role of Princess Margaret
here's what she had to share about what
makes the show so curious for us viewers
there's all the big kind of uh epic
stories going on the stories that
everyone knows about because their
history but then there's all the little
quiet dramas going on underneath
number three Mr Price sees him as just a
man several of the actors who have been
tasked with playing these public figures
on the crown have shared a feeling of
intimidation over their roles Jonathan
price was no exception when it came to
playing the Duke of Edinburgh price said
it took me a while to relax and think of
what I'm doing as just my version of a
man called Prince Philip who happens to
be called Prince Philip so the more I
could relax the more freedom I gave
myself the closer I got to the character
number 4. Debicki is Diana Elizabeth
Debicki delivers the role of Princess
Diana in the crown and here's what she
had to share about becoming Diana for
the show as a result of the marriage
breaking down and how she becomes more
and more removed from the rest of the
royal family that of course sort of
encourages her to grow other pieces of
her life and attempt to sort of recoup
control of the ones that feel like
they're spiraling number five he got a
very special letter actor Dominic West
takes the role of Prince Charles Dominic
is among the few actors on the crown
that has some ties to the real-life
royal family he actually holds the
position of ambassador of the prince's
trust a charity of which King Charles is
President and Dominic offered to quit
his position as Ambassador when he
learned he got the role in case of a
conflict of interest his resignation
offer was refused via a letter from King
Charles's private secretary which said
you do what you like you're an actor
it's nothing to do with us number six
it's not easy being a prince the crown
actor Josh O'Connor shares how he felt
somewhat intimidated by the task of
playing his role here's what Josh had to
say about his two seasons playing Prince
Charles you read those scripts and all
you can think is I just want to
effectively tell this story and portray
it in the way that Peter has written it
if it's not my job to tell the true
story of Prince Charles that's not what
we're doing at all
number seven it was a lunch to remember
Emma Corin brings us an uncanny
resemblance to Princess Diana with her
performance in the role Emma had some
unusual and immersive experiences as an
actor working on the crown here's what
she shared she had one scene alone with
Emerald fennel too shortly before her
wedding Diana has an excruciating lunch
with Camilla at menajahtwa I remember
that day so well I had the worst period
Pains of my life I had a bucket on the
floor because I thought I was going to
be sick I think it helped because I was
so physically uncomfortable it added to
the scene because I didn't need to play
her English
number eight Queen for a season or two
it's hard to think of the crown without
thinking in part of Olivia Coleman as
Queen Elizabeth II when asked how she
felt about moving from her experience
with the show here's what Olivia had to
share as an actor I am excited to play
other roles but I have enjoyed this job
so much and I will miss sitting with and
laughing with everyone on set we really
were having the time of our lives and
that group of people will be a very hard
act to follow number nine they're more
than monarchs actor Tobias Menzies
brings us two seasons of Prince Philip
on the crown and he shares his thoughts
on how writer and producer Peter Morgan
brings these private yet public figures
to life as dramatic characters Tobias
says I like the way Peter takes quite a
strong position on certain characters
and imagining how they might think or
feel because that's the bit history
doesn't recount to us
number 10 we can only imagine the drama
there are some viewers who believe that
the crown should show a fiction
disclaimer in front of each episode The
Crown actor Helena Bonham Carter who
brought us two seasons in the role of
Princess Margaret said on the show's
official podcast she thought the series
had a moral responsibility to declare
that it was our version rather than the
real version Helena said it is
dramaticized I do feel very strongly
because I think we have a moral
responsibility to say hang on guys this
is not it's not a drama dog we're making
a drama so they are two different
entities number 11 it sadly became a
little too real Aaron Doherty played
young Princess Anne in the crown and we
wondered what she had to say about
watching the Queen's funeral was it
strange yes we spent two years imagining
what those people's lives were like
there was sadness for the family but on
some level the experience of making the
crown made it more beautiful I'm always
asked what I would say if I ever met
Princess Anne and I just don't know I
think the world of her I really really
love her but she's also intimidating to
me
number 12 a person to admire an
experience to forget Claire Foy brings
us two seasons as both princess and then
Queen Elizabeth II and while we imagine
it would be a challenging yet rewarding
show to work on Claire says she would
never want to revisit certain moments
that she filmed in the crown saying
she's been visibly a mother and held
down a job I related to that she's an
icon someone to look up to and respect
in season 2 there are scenes I would
never want to relive
number 13 she got just a little bit too
excited the crown actor Vanessa Kirby
brings us two seasons of Princess
Margaret when asked about some of the
ways she prepared for the role here's
what she had to say I've got pictures of
her everywhere which I think is quite
disturbing for anyone who comes over and
doesn't know that I play her the reason
that I have that one on my wall in the
bedroom is I was hoping that by osmosis
I would absorb some of her and also
because it really defined how the
sisters could be less alike I really
wanted to look at that when I'd wake up
and maybe Channel a bit of it Vanessa
got to meet one of Margaret's ladies in
Waiting who said she almost got it
perfect Vanessa admitted she said the
performance was perfect which was so
flattering I couldn't believe it I
nearly died she said the only thing was
that during the wedding you were a
little bit too bubbly Margaret would
have taken it much more seriously number
14 you know you've wondered about it we
certainly have did Queen Elizabeth ever
watch the show we have been wondering
this since season one it seems that
someone has the answer Matt Smith who
played Prince Philip in season 1 and 2
heard that Queen Elizabeth had watched
the show he said the queen had watched
it oh yeah yeah and she used to watch it
on a projector on a Sunday night
apparently as the show slowly catches up
to present day we're curious to see what
other stories come from the ever-growing
cast we're sure there are other hidden
gems from the cast about making the show
so what did we miss what do you think
let us know in the comments below